so everyone asks me how I got my job at
Vox I'll warn you now if you're
interested in this look at how long this
video is it's not a two-minute video
this is not a short answer I am going to
tell the story of how this all worked
out for me and maybe you can glean some
lessons for yourself I am in Utah and I
am very happy to be in Utah
I have snuck away into the mountains for
a moment because that's what you do when
you're in Utah I have about 20 minutes
right now before I'm meeting up with a
friend who I only know from the internet
but he's another filmmaker named Brad
and we're gonna hang out and fly drones
so I recently talked about how I got
started making videos and you haven't
seen that I'm gonna link it here it's
the first part of this story where I
left off there was basically I was this
kid who tinkered around with my parents
camcorder for years the film major for a
hot second and then dropped out because
I was disillusioned with the program but
kept making stuff I married a girl who
also like to make stuff and that's how I
got started how did I turn that into a
professional situation where I was
suddenly making stuff for bigger
organizations or for a place like Vox
and that story begins in April of 2013
are you limping I'm even working out
[Music]
what are we really doing see so we
graduated from college and that same
week also is he had a baby that wasn't
the most practical decision and then we
moved across the country to Washington
DC where I didn't have a job lined up
we had a baby we had about $1,300 in our
bank account and yeah we were feeling
really good about life that $1,300 we
had in the bank came from a research
grant that I got in college to go do
field research in Peru so we moved to
Washington DC I went to Peru
[Music]
and at that point I thought I was going
to be getting a job in international
relations I was like I'm probably gonna
be a diplomat or something like that
well it turns out that it's really hard
to get a job in international relations
in Washington DC there are a lot of
people who have just graduated who are
looking for jobs and there was no way I
was gonna find anything better than an
internship and so while I was in Peru I
came to this conclusion that I really
had to leverage my video skills and
remember where we're at here my video
skills are nothing special like they're
a bunch of home movies a little bit of
motion graphics that I had done but I
was not I did not have a strong
portfolio of work or a really developed
skill set but what I did have is a big
desire to pivot and say I'm gonna go
full into video and make a career out of
making stuff so while I was in Peru I
cobbled together all of the work I
possibly could all of the dummy projects
all of the stuff that looked at all
decent and I put it on to a portfolio
website that I built with a basic
WordPress template and I started to
apply the jobs
Wow the top of this hill I put together
this pretty weak portfolio everything I
possibly could and this was me scraping
the bottom of the barrel to say like at
least know how to make some stuff this
is lesson number one of this store and I
didn't realize it then but I realized it
now I had my expectations really low I
was like man I don't deserve to be
making really amazing stuff for really
amazing places
so I wasn't applying to my dream jobs I
was applying to any job that would get
my hands on the tools that will allow me
to make more stuff and to get better at
this stuff that's all I wanted I wanted
someone to pay me to just play with
After Effects and play with the camera
we literally needed money like like I
had a brand-new child and as he was
recovering from pregnancy so I started
working in a restaurant cutting
vegetables I've always wanted to work in
a restaurant I kind of loved culinary
stuff it's an amazing experience and it
and it paid the bills so after a month
of searching and working
restaurant I finally found a job in
motion graphics I was going to be making
video for not box not the New York Times
not National Geographic but for an
architecture regulation firm nothing
that had anything to do with what I'd
studied nothing that I was interested in
but the key component here is that they
were paying me for 40 hours a week to
sit down and to make stuff in
after-effects and there I learned a ton
I stepped up and started to learn so
much about how everything works in these
programs and I started to make a lot of
stuff and it wasn't stuff I loved and it
wasn't stuff that was pushing me
creatively but it was stuff I was making
stuff got to make so much freaking stuff
and I was doing it and I was getting
paid for it
it's getting close to meeting up with
Brad time I should head back down and
hopefully I don't slip on this little
snow so I worked there for the rest of
2013 and then I saw a job open up at a
think-tank and International Affairs
think-tank they wanted someone to make
videos for them and I was like boom this
is my next step like I now know how to
make motion graphics and I had done some
dummy projects on the side that kind of
looked like you know maps and stuff so I
applied there to this think-tank CSIs is
the name of the think-tank and got the
job and again was this my dream job was
this what I wanted to be doing for the
rest of my life no but was this a job
that got me one stepping-stone closer to
what I did want to be doing in my life I
was able to put my hands on the tools
for 40 hours a week and I was doing
something in had to do with
international stuff which was closer to
my wheelhouse so suddenly this kid this
kid is now slowly starting to round
himself out as a professional video
person but this is a lot of time in the
trenches and this is a lot of intensity
when it comes to learning new things and
pushing myself during the process but
you can start to see the transformation
at CSIS I really start to dig into
mapping into storytelling into
explanation into honing what my kind of
voices my writing voice this skill set
starts to become more and more refined
into something that's professional and
not just a hobby okay so now it is early
2014 and voxcom is born I remember the
day I saw a box for the first time it's
like in April 2014 it was like a
healthcare videos in animation and I
watched that video and out loud I said
to myself in an empty room I will work
for these people I will do whatever it
takes to work for these people and I
knew that didn't mean just like passion
and perseverance it meant like I have to
get the skills to work for these people
so suddenly my work days were not just
you know trying to slowly refine it was
like how do I refine my skills to be
good enough to work at box
that became the goal so after a couple
of months I applied for a position at
box and an animator position came up I
applied for it and I got rejected I
wasn't good enough at that time I really
wasn't
I was left distraught and stewing on
what on earth I could do to get hired at
mode
it was exactly four years ago from right
now in Thanksgiving break of 2014 that I
decided I was going to make a video
specifically for Vox that was my pitch
on why they should hire me and over that
Thanksgiving break I poured my soul into
making that video I called it my video
resume and it was like the five reasons
I would be an asset to your team here
take a just a moment to watch a section
of this video so you can get a flavor of
what I'm talking about here
I am a multimedia generalist based in
the Washington DC area and my whole
thing is that I'm interested in
connecting high quality media arts with
foreign affairs I pored over this video
I remember being in the airport on the
way back from Florida where is these
parents were living at a time I remember
I had to board the flight but I had
these like through the 3d section of it
I was rendering in cinema 4d and I was
like I can't like let this stop
rendering cuz I have to finish it like
on the plane and so I downloaded this
extension called power nap where you can
leave your computer on
after you close at your laptop and it
will continue to run and so I did that
like really quick and then I like closed
my laptop and let it render the 3d stuff
like while I had it in my backpack and
it was an obsession it was a literal
obsession like I have to do this so I
finished the video and I sent it to Joe
and Joe responded yes and that started
an ongoing conversation that lasted a
few months that ended in a job offer at
Vox hmm yes I'm gonna give you a couple
of takeaways that I think are useful
from this story I don't just want it to
be a story I want it to also be like
maybe some lessons the first takeaway is
the exact same as the one I did in the
in the previous video which is you don't
need a gatekeeper to validate that you
are professional I don't have a degree
in filmmaking or InDesign or animation
or in journalism but I was able to enter
into this craft and the skill set and
I'm able to do it now you don't need a
gatekeeper to validate you the second
takeaway is about understanding the long
game of developing professional skills
the long game perspective here is that
you find a job that allows you to get
better at the skills that you need to
get better at that job probably won't be
the ideal perfect job that you want it
won't be your dream job but it's gotta
be a job that gives you a large body of
repetitive work on doing the same thing
that you want to be doing in your dream
job if you want to get into journalism
that could be going to a local paper and
writing a ton of stories in and learning
how to be edited
a traditional editor if you're a
filmmaker that might be shooting
weddings if you're a designer that may
be like designing for your like local
like school newspaper something actually
did that in college I designed for our
political newspaper and learn design
skills not because it was my dream job
and that's what I wanted to do but
because I wanted an opportunity to put
my hands on the tools and to get
experience and repetition in those tools
okay I got to go run to pick up Brad now
but the last takeaway here I'm gonna
call the prove that you're worth hiring
take away what I mean by this is if you
really want to work at a place and you
really believe that you have this skill
set then prove it like prove it like
show don't tell I get emails all the
time from people who are like I love box
box is like my dream it's like so great
and I want to work there like III is
there a job and I'm thinking you're
telling me that you're passionate about
box and that therefore you should be
hired that's not like proof like a
million people are passionate about box
if you feel like you should be hired
prove it like show me in fact the emails
I like the most or when people are like
hey check this thing out and it's like a
link that the perfect example is my
experience with Joe I sent him an email
with my application didn't hear anything
I sent him a very short probably one
line that was like look at this video
resume boom I got an interview show
don't tell that is like not only a
lesson for storytelling but that is a
lesson for getting the job that you want
develop the skills and then prove that
you
if I rambled enough I'm gonna get in my
car now my hands a little cold here in
the shadow of these giant Rocky
Mountains I'm gonna go pick up Brad and
we are gonna go fly some drones
I've got Brad Devine here teaching me
the ways of the new drone I've been like
it's a good marginally piney bit bigger
yeah this is whatever you call your
owner I found him on the explore phase I
might do that ever since and he still
talks me off he's always one of the
Mount Fuji recently pose I hope my long
story about how it all worked out with
Vox is helpful please leave comments let
me know if you have follow-up questions
I'm happy to get more detail and as
always these videos are for me to answer
questions that I can't answer in emails
and other things so please just tell me
your other questions and if I get a lot
of them I will make a video about them
alright thanks so much have a good day
[Music]